okay so
uh very commonly living bend the guy
down
he comes up and then you throw
it doesn't matter whether you're doing
the tencon version of the very common
tank conversation
okay i don't i don't care the version i
just want to look at
when he comes
uh straight back through perfect posture
before he comes to here
okay that when he passes through
perfect posture
right here is where he is perfectly
able to counter me with any series of
things so he can resist
right he can uh let's say he's gonna
bend
back and throw me this way over and over
i'm gonna go
like a cushion all right
you also he can fall very gently
underneath me here
also you can turn in the
in the soft high breakfall so that's
what allows him to set up the forward
break ball okay but we don't want that
because
where he's turning for that front high
breakfall
is where he can do any one of those
counters he's not in my control
so what we want to do instead
is start to tilt him
and he never passes back through here
he's on this tilt here
then we want to do it at a certain
timing so as i tilt him
if i stop his forward progress he can
still
turn on this foot and then do any of all
those other things
so you have to check him with his
forward progress
you have to keep his energy going that
way
as you tilting him tilting
but moving so he moves go ahead and move
he's going like this
then he can't turn the foot then he
can't
counter because he never passes through
his posture
he can't turn because energy's going
that way and he can't
posture because i never bring his head
back inside his base of support
so he has to go forward
until forward
and tilt
okay let's try that okay so
she's allowed to keep going and there's
the
that's the kazushi you want you see do
you get it and so
john's observation was she
she's already falling
you don't really need the throw and
that's exactly right okay
so but the throw is doing something else
okay
so i'll use
so as he's coming around boom
i have to be wary of this arm
okay and my technique
needs to happen in front of this
do you see not
in front of him okay so the way you can
think of it is
from my perspective i'm in front of his
arm from his perspective i'm in the back
you get that and this creates a body
lock
oh my my torso is in here
when we go fast my leg will be in there
too my whole body is going to be in
there
to control he can't turn into me
see there's a lock and that's what i use
this row that's a body lock very much
like we're here
and i come around like this
same exact technique okay so
i'm in here and i'm i lock on his body
you give me nugget of the torso okay you
you want this body lock
and it's behind this arm here
then there's a strategic component if
i'm not going to do anything with him
he does not land under me okay so
if i was gonna do something with him i
won't
land under me okay maybe i'm going for
a lock or maybe i'm dispatching the
weapon
but if i don't have something to do with
him
the arm is projecting him away from me
that body lock was projecting him
[Music]
away from me okay just like
a cocky projection he's moving away from
me
okay so that's what the
second part of the throat does he's
already falling in the first part
in the second part i'm doing a body lock
and project him out from under me he he
doesn't get to choose just
we're here he doesn't get to choose out
he goes
okay so we go in take his balance
not underneath you not underneath
not underneath you he doesn't get to
choose that
so
out away from you okay
okay so when when the ukia is able to
get their arm around you
you see that that's a counter
and it's because you didn't understand
the elbow check
in the technique okay so i'm doing
everything we'll go slow so you can see
i know that i got to get that arm
behind my uh rib cage
okay that that's where the body lock
exists that's where the body
body lock exists if i have the gap
if i have a gap there's no body lock
you're
just accelerating him okay
so this part of the technique i have to
feel that elbow
behind my rib cage that's that's the
technique
and usually when you don't feel that
it's because you moved in front of the
you're now in front of luke and there's
no check on his elbow so this arm can
come around
okay so it's still different that he's
down
and i'm trying to pass past his guard i
i know that i gotta get on the other
side of this scene
in front of in front of his hip if i'm
going to do the knee slice okay
i can't put it somewhere else because i
didn't really clear the guard so
i got to get my knee in front of his hip
so i'm going to get my back
from my perspective in front of his
elbow in front of his elbow
okay from my perspective
my back goes in front of his elbow
it gets delayed just long enough
for me to project him away you want to
be so
cognizant of that check that if you feel
his arm go around
that's a different technique that's a
different technique
and you should not be seeking um
because he has too much control and you
have to change your tactic
i got to deal with the guy that's
underneath me okay
so you shouldn't practice to effa
but you're very aware he got inside
so just here and i'll land here in
case of atonement okay just land here
so let's do two where you work on not
giving the opening
get the elbow check and then two
where you give the opening and find
uh there
okay so again you asked up and he got
his arm there you should feel that arm
you should feel it cap the elbow enter
twist and try to go you have your butt
go
straight down okay straight down you
don't want any inertia going forward
because that's when he's going to
encounter you
so keep your eyes on your butt your butt
is going straight down so i make the
mistake
palms my twenties going straight down
butt's going straight down
you know you'll feel the ribs strike as
you go okay
and we'll just stop here at this stance
there he did it in
here
no inertia going over you you should
feel the counter coming because you gave
the opening
okay and so down
this time not out anyway